I did put some bling on my chairs you
all know I love my bling what's the
daily Glam budget in this house because
it has to be up there it's a lot it's a
couple
thousand dollars a day for sure
Kim Zolciak biermann's house is now safe
from The Auction Block I'm here until I
want to move out after E.T confirmed the
former Real Housewives of Atlanta Star
and hubby Kroy are in foreclosure on
their 17
000 square foot Georgia Mansion
according out of the king and queen of
this house a lot has changed the
auction originally slated for March 7th
is now canceled according to the law
office handling the Foreclosure no word
yet on the reason and as far as we know
the bank still plans to auction the home
off but a new date has yet to be
scheduled E.T has reached out to Kim for
comment I mean it's drama according to a
notice posted on Wednesday the
Foreclosure is due to the couple
defaulting on a 1.65 million dollar loan
they took out in 2012. this is Paradise
right here for me the house is opulent
to say the least six bedrooms nine
bathrooms and a decade of calling it
home it's been very very fun
ET spoke with Kim and Croy around the
time they bought the house it was
shortly after tying the knot and the
former NFL star became stepdad to Kim's
two daughters from previous
relationships from day one I've had a
connection with Brielle and Ariana and
it's just continued to grow we've had to
go through quite a few things with
moving and babies amid the family's
crisis Kim's eldest Brielle posted this
early birthday gift from her mom a two
thousand dollar pair of shoes people
call me a gold digger but they just want
what I have the reality star is an OG
Peach holder but she left the franchise
After Five Seasons I mean from crying
babies to screaming KJ to Brielle
wanting something I mean it's just
chaotic still she stayed in the Bravo
verse with Don't Be Tardy a docu-series
focused on her and kroy's life at home
with six children this is my favorite
room in the whole house it's called the
Hollywood room and this is actually my
girls like TV room where they hang out
with their friends and I am obsessed
with this room you know sometimes Fame
and money do change people but God can
take it from me as quick as he gave it
to you
[Music]